all right some of you know a friend of
the David Pakman show Sam cedar he hosts
the majority report formerly of Air
America he's a voice or maybe even
multiple voices at this point on the
cartoon Bob's Burgers and an MSNBC
contributor and some of you might also
be aware of this right-wing alt-right
troll named Mike Tsarevich who himself
has been accused of rape
well CERN if it's found an old tweet of
Sam's this is a clearly satirical tweet
and that that we're going to show you
the tweet and Serna vich started making
a huge deal out of it and the alt-right
followers of his went completely bonkers
demanding that sam be fired from his
MSNBC contributor ship they started
lobbying Sam's advertisers to cancel
their advertising many of the same
advertisers that we have on the show
because Sam and I both work with the
same advertising agency and the tweet
which were gonna show you relates to
Roman Polanski Roman Pinet Polanski is
this film director who was arrested and
charged in the 70s with raping a
thirteen-year-old girl and that have
taken a plea bargain for lesser charges
but then he fled the United States even
with the lesser charges he was facing
jail time he fled the US and has been
living in Europe ever since and years
ago in 2009 Sam tweeted about that issue
quote I don't care or don't care
regarding Polanski but I hope if my
daughter is ever raped it is by an older
truly talented man with a great sense of
meson son the the film term referring to
sort of the composition of a scene on
camera
well no big deal right because I'm sure
every alt right free speech keyboard
warrior is going to be out there
defending Sam cedar to the death because
after all it's clearly a joke and
they're not triggered they're not the PC
police or any of the stuff that they
criticized the left for not exactly Mike
Serna vich uncovered this tweet and he
tweeted hi Chris Hayes care to comment
on this tweet by your colleague Sam
cedar now you could say you can never
joke about rape right you you could take
some kind of absolutist position
and if you want to do that go ahead and
do it but the people complaining about
Sam's tweet are not the people who take
those absolutist positions that they
usually ascribe to those on the Left
talked about some people are saying that
this is a defense of pedophilia that Sam
did by making a joke about Roman
Polanski anybody really think that
anybody thinks Sam cedar was defending
pedophilia put put aside for a moment
that every other time that Sam commented
on Roman Polanski
it was absolutely and obviously critical
of the disgusting acts that Roman
Polanski was accused of this is obvious
satire right and the hypocrisy czar
stunning and multiple number one you
have these alt-right trolls who claim to
be against outraged culture but yet they
went to MSNBC and to sam cedars
advertisers saying we're outraged over a
clearly satirical eight-year-old tweet
that's hypocrisy number one now
hypocrisy number two is about mike Serna
vich and it's not the hypocrisy that
mike Serna vich himself was accused of
actual rape and ultimately that charge
was reduced to misdemeanor battery but
forget about that right in his own 2015
book this guy mike stern of it said he
believes date rape is a liberal fiction
what is more outrageous Sam's obvious
satirical tweet from eight years ago or
someone saying there is no such thing as
date rape Serna vich also wrote in 2012
that date rape does not exist and the
same people claiming to be outraged over
Sam's tweet seem not to care about what
Mike Serna vich himself has said over
the years about rape they seem not to
care that our president was accused of
actual sexual assault by more than a
dozen women that the guy running for
Senate in Alabama was accused of actual
sexual assault by half a dozen women
some of whom were under the age of
consent at the time of the alleged
incidents how can anyone be so concerned
about a 2009 joke from sam cedar and yet
not be activists against Donald Trump
and Roy Moore the group supposedly
against political correctness and
against the policing of speech is
policing speech by
going after someone accused of doing
nothing other than making a joke that it
worst was I don't know insensitive to
some degree in any case MSNBC is cutting
off ties with Sam strictly speaking
they're not firing him but they are
saying he's not scheduled to be back on
before February which is when his
contract ends and we're not going to be
renewing that contract and my issue is
not so much that MSNBC fired Sam or call
it what you want won't be renewing his
contract that's what these corporations
do in these situations
it's the hypocrisy of the lynch mob that
made this an issue in the first place
and Sam's real mistake here if there was
one is deleting the tweet in question
and he said on his program that if he
could go back he wouldn't have deleted
the tweet I understand the reaction this
starts blowing up people are attacking
your livelihood and you say what can I
do I'll delete the tweet which as we
learned from Donald Trump deleting
tweets and whoever else they don't
really go away I do believe that Sam
will will ultimately persevere here but
just absolutely and totally pathetic